[Music]
Janelle Monae formally comes out if
it'll make me spell it out for ya after
speculation surrounding her sexuality
and releasing her hit song made me feel
people called it a bisexual anthem the
singer reveals she's pansexual in
Rolling Stone magazine Janelle opens up
in the latest issue telling the mad
quote being a black queer woman in
America someone who has been in
relationships with both men and women I
consider myself to be a free mother for
there be a woman or a person of color or
someone you know a part of the LGBTQ
community you name it I think that we
have to let their voices be heard she
initially identified as bisexual but has
now voiced being more gender fluid quote
later I read about Penn sexuality and I
was like oh these are things that I
identify with too over the years Janelle
has been romantically linked to Tessa
Thompson who was featured in several of
the singers dirty computer music videos
et chatted with Tessa back in February
about their rumored relationship Janelle
and I have been really close from so
lucky to have her in my life I met her
in an audition as for the inspiration
behind Janelle's the music quote I want
young girls young boys non-binary gay
straight queer people who are having a
hard time dealing with their sexuality
to know that I see you adding this album
is for you be proud that's just the way
you make me feel